hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
we're gonna check out the trailer today
for the witch the Witch stars people
I've never heard of let's watch this
rated R for disturbing violent content
and graphic nudity oh boy I know you're
excited
hey fending but disturbing context than
nudity together festival oh cool what
went way out into this wilderness to
find
leaving our country kindred our fathers
houses for what for the kingdom of God
let us pray
Creedy Oh 824 it's got like a old-school
lot to it other than that that takes
place at this time yes - I'd like
tension-filled woman there aren't a lot
of fun
Oh
wait Robert
town its curse this family
we can oh hello lemur center consumer
should be
potentially never show this room
there's these the pork dude oh man
horrified yeah I know yeah look I got
chill nipple chills nipple chills touch
that nipple touch that nipple it's rock
hard rock our nipple I just broke that
controller my nipple slice through it
just that trailer alone I was like it
looks like just a nightmarish experience
ya know I mean they don't always feel
good but I'm glad we're getting some
witch movies like this you know taking
it back to the like the time when
witchcraft was really like I got burned
the witch like those times yeah I'm
really good with eras that's how I refer
to it well you know I mean those are
like the puritanical times those were
those were like the early America you
know when the pilgrims came I mean those
it was probably past then but you know
there still had sort of the older garb
and you know sort of Civil War
not quite World War two yeah I love the
way this film is shot there's a lot of
really cool shots in here it really
looks like they're letting the tension
Duma like there's really no jump scares
in this trailer
well the production value is great oh
yeah the costume designs and everything
work amazing it looks like it's shot in
a very confident way not necessarily
really flashy way but like it's like
there's not a bad shot in the trailer
like everything seems like it was there
for a purpose it does I get that said
like seeing this trailer unfold it's all
it does sort of feel like you're peering
in on something you shouldn't
necessarily have stumbled on yeah with
the characters you don't really get much
character in this trailer but I'm
already like we might get suspense for
who died I get a good sense of these did
that woman at least playing with the
baby she looks like a good human being
and I don't want to see her go through
that well yeah and hopefully I mean you
know it all come together with the movie
but it seems like the performances are
potentially good enough that they just
communicate you can tell by looking at
you know the older woman
the younger woman or even the dude with
the muscle you can tell probably who
these people are and why they got to
these positions what I really like about
the trailer is it seems like it's really
using environment when you're going back
to something we shouldn't be seeing it's
like it's a it's a rather normal
environment you know it's but for that
time period it's it's that's normal so
it's like you're peering into the lives
of these people yeah at very terrifying
time in their lives you know using like
sort of a more subtle strangeness it's
like you know these weird shots of goats
- and stuff like that when the one like
rears up and almost looks like it's
gonna change somehow like there's like
subtle hints - like demonic things in
this trailer which I like and I have a
feeling it's gonna be one of those
horrifying experiences throughout this a
lot of build-up and the finale is just
gonna be like [ __ ] terrifying full of
demons and [ __ ] I don't know if you
would necessarily explode I think it'll
get really psychologically dark yeah I
leave feeling ugly probably trailer
predictions you know I like it goes not
a ghost movie which movie like this you
know cuz I'm glad that there does seem
to be like a pocket now where there's
like in horror and and it's sort of
brother genres there is a concentrated
effort to make witch stories right now
which is just me because we have ghosts
and demons all the time yeah so it's
like ah some actual witches and we need
to be aware that witches still exist to
this day yeah you know not this way
exactly what I think is movie so [ __ ]
scary what not exactly not know what
it's like to be alone with Veronica
she's always burning something and like
chanting in the corner the breeze dead
crows home that's horrible
are you sure you're not thinking of a
cat no was this is not a cat it's
Veronica you see her bringing room yeah
that's [ __ ] up he's always using that
broomstick yeah to get to her yeah all
the clean oh and she just had one that
makes her fly she just cleans a lot
oh yeah no yeah which is like it
climbing the crow blood never seen a
dirty witch in the house when you mix it
with the cat food
hey guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out reason
mr. Jerry and dank ass dubs hosted by
sir Jerry oh man this channel oh man and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine periscope I Dream of
Jeannie Charles
Mitchell hello I'm the lead actor writer
producer oh you're one of those guys
like I'm gonna I'm gonna do everything
for this so he's not directing cool you
let something go for a new horror film
called cold silence cold silence
interesting interesting cold silence
it's like when it's silent it's a little
chilly outside
we are hoping that some of you film
geeks and horror nerds would come over
and check us out this film will be
different and unique as compared to
other horror films of its genre great
pitch and gave me nothing to work off of
of how it's gonna be unique other than
the fact that you're saying it's unique
what is its genre is it like a sub-genre
that you're dealing with is this some
kind of creature feature 19 year old
sean is sent to live with his mother and
her family outside of Seattle only to
encounter an ancient Native American
demon who interesting interesting okay
okay
maybe I am a little intrigued the only
way I will truly promote this film is if
you give me a part in it I don't care
how small it is I want a part in your
film cold silence I can play Native
Americans let's start like a hello Lone
Ranger yeah Tonto see and go to Indian
guy my name is Tonto don't ever do that
again he sounds like Johnny Depp just a
little war out there a little louder
anyway yeah I want to play Tonto when
you're gonna follow that I was like I
gotta think of an impression I just
don't and you got this girl Megan
Latrell in there yeah okay so if I get
cast in this film no kissing that I need
a sexy but no kissing I would be
cheating on my you're like I'm Frost a
to be cheating on my girlfriend you can
do anything you want sex scenes just
simulating and holding so Tim it if you
can create a sex scene with me and this
actually you know what you have the same
name as my sister never
Oh